this camped near the port in Calais is
home for a group of Iranian migrants but
they hope not for much longer
they're dreamed to get to Britain is
often promised by smugglers who come
here almost daily
Ahmed paid 500 euros to a man who took
him hidden in the back of a van to a
beach with seven other migrants and
after we got there and the boat is ready
everything is ready for pass across they
said I go and I come back with the
driver okay but he go and don't come
back the driver and after he saw us and
we don't go and he come and with the
knife he said if you don't turn on and
go don't go I kill you he says this is a
picture of the boat taken after they
were eventually rescued
we can't independently verify the images
they were stranded for eight hours at
sea after the engine cut out and the
boat filled with water he was taken back
to France and detained by the
authorities before being released why
the UK ydy UK because my family live in
UK my sister he translates for Ali who
tells me he had a similar experience he
attempted the journey just four days ago
desperate to reach England where his
wife and young son are living after
getting in on a lorry three months ago
why now why try now because now the
smuggler works with boats you can find
the smuggler very easily
yeah his boat was intercepted after six
hours in the channel he claims he was
detained handcuffed and kicked by French
police
charities like care for Cali provide the
basics for migrants but life here is
harsh and the future uncertain charity
workers are seeing more people willing
to try anything to get out a natural
tell us all we really need to know about
the situation here in Cali it is a
really desperate one and is one where
people are willing to risk their lives
because they have no other option
patrolling the channel HMC searcher it
will soon be joined by two more border
force cutters after the Home Secretary
announced extra measures to help secure
the border and prevent deaths in Calais
there's a sense that nothing will stop
people trying people here are desperate
and even though some have tried the
treacherous journey and failed to make
it to Britain they're still willing to
take the risk again if they get the
opportunity there's still hope here that
2019 is the year they'll finally reached
their destination Becky Johnson Sky News
Calais